catastrophe nationale en espagne 26
mille hectares détruits par le feu en
catalogne la population est mobilisée
aux côtés des sauveteurs mais manque de
moyens une étape terrible dans les
pyrénées l'allemand jan ullrich reprend
le maillot jaune les directeurs sportifs
exige des contrôles antidopages
renforcée pour chasser le malaise qui
plane toujours sur la course le
gouvernement confirmera demain qui ne
taxera pas les oeuvres d'art dans
l'impôt sur la fortune et qu'il changera
le calcul et allégera la taxe
professionnelle qui pèse sur les
entreprises
en ce début d'été les fruits sont plutôt
rares et chères explication la météo du
printemps qui a sérieusement endommagé
des récoltes
la mode de l'hiver prochain défilé haute
couture chanel la croix ce soir madame
monsieur bonsoir l' incendie qui ravage
depuis quatre jours maintenant le
nord-est de la catalogne dans la région
de barcelone a détruit à 7h26 mille
hectares de bois et de culture la faire
tourner à la catastrophe nationale en
espagne où près de 2000 pompiers
volontaires assisté de plusieurs
hélicoptères et avions bombardiers d'eau
ce relais pour endiguer la progression
du feu des canadairs français sont même
intervenus en renfort ce soir la
première bonne nouvelle est arrivée les
conditions météo se sont améliorées cet
après midi la chaleur est un peu tombé
et le vent souffle en sens contraire de
la progression des flammes sur place en
espagne les moyens employés sur le
terrain reste réduit malgré la bonne
volonté générale ce qui explique
peut-être l'ampleur du désastre
reportage vincent nguyen josé boulesteix
quelques branches contre les flammes
assurément ces gens là ne sont pas
pompier et pourtant on a arrêté il reste
des petits départs de fin çà et là ce
sont des catalans des gens du coin
avec les moyens du bord la nuit dernière
ils se sont battus comme des lions un
barrage humain contre un mur de feu de
25 kg même si je ne sauve qu'à l'arbre
pour moi c'est suffisant ce sera l'arbre
je suis content mais ce soir je pense
que j'en ai sauvé plus d'un ce matin ils
avaient les traits tirés à la caserne
des volontaires de tora un véritable
quartier général où toute la population
s'est mobilisée jour et nuit
aujourd'hui encore de nouveaux bénévoles
afflué de toute la catalogne la
catalogne face aux événements on est un
peuple fondre c'est une tradition
les pompiers sont moins nombreux et la
population fait partie du dispositif
terme des tracteurs sont mobilisés
on a toujours ses citernes en cas de
besoin les autorités forestières une
chapelle et dès qu'on peut on aller les
civils ont appris sur le tas et malgré
leur manque de formation
c'est parfois eux qui tiennent la lance
du pompier dans le personnel civil
les paysans sont organisés en comité
feux de forêt et joue un rôle très
important dans la lutte contre ces gros
incendie part sans eux je sens cette
entraide peu orthodoxe a porté ses
fruits et cet après-midi pompiers et
civiles ont vu leurs efforts récompensés
ce soir la plupart des incendies
semblent sous contrôle et la population
catalan va enfin pouvoir se reposer
simplement il devra rester vigilante à
cause de ses fumerolles qui un peu
partout dans la montagne menacent de
s'enflammer si le vent revient à
souffler je vous le disais en commençant
ce soir ce sont donc 26 mille hectares
de bois et de culture qui ont brûlé et
des images aériennes notamment qui nous
parviennent montrent bien l'ampleur de
la catastrophe lance bukiya 27 mille
hectares détruits soit près de trois
fois la surface de paris dans cette zone
du nord-est de l'espagne
écologiquement très riche 6 millions
d'arbres principalement des pins sont
partis en fumée sur le front de
l'incendié ravageur près de 2000
personnes combattent donc les et
volontaire avions et hélicoptères
bombardiers d'eau appareils de
reconnaissance camions citernes ce matin
après trois jours de 20 minutes les
pompiers ça vous êtes enfin un peu plus
optimiste est effectivement cet après
midi pour la première fois
l'incendié semble stabiliser la
température extérieure a baissé de 5
degrés l'air est plus humide et le vent
a changé d'avis il repousse maintenant
les flammes vers les zones déjà brûlé
signe de l'accalmie
contrairement à hier aucune évacuation
de population n'a été organisée
mais pour les catalans cet incendie et
de triste mémoire
il y a quatre ans quatre-vingt mille
hectares de leurs forêts avaient déjà
brûlé ce soir toute la catalogne espère
la pluie sur le tour de france cycliste
victoire aujourd'hui dans la première
étape de montagne dans les pyrénées de
l'italien massi le favori l'allemand jan
ullrich reprend le maillot jaune nous y
reviendrons dans un instant pour le
moment revenons sur les conséquences de
la sphère de dopage qui a touché
l'équipe festina le souci des directeurs
sportifs des équipes qui demeure dans la
compétition et de chasser le sentiment
de malaise qui désormais plane sur ce
sport et à cet effet ils ont demandé que
les contrôles en iep antidopage soit
renforcée reportage avec 120 car à
nathalie gallet pas c'est une affaire
qui continue de jeter sur le tour de
france le doute généralisé
les directeurs sportifs très attaquées
depuis les aveux de mun roussel cherche
aujourd'hui à reprendre l'initiative
avec cette grave affaire qui est apparu
sur pour de france la résultat des
courses on a l'impression que tout le
les équipes sont à la même enseigne je
crois que ça c'est très dommageable
il est agent qui sont sérieux qui
travaillent qui sont honnêtes
après s'être réuni les directeurs
sportifs ont demandé à lui saisi
l'instance internationale du cyclisme
des mesures immédiates la rédaction
d'une charte des directeurs sportifs
la présence dans chaque équipe d'un
médecin responsable devant lui seyait
l'obligation d'employer des masseurs
licenciés salariés enfin la mise en
place immédiate du nouveau règlement de
contrôle de santé prévue à l'origine
pour le 1er janvier 99 suivi médical
les groupes de sportifs des équipes
doivent suivre avec avec des prises de
sang est régulièrement tous les tous les
trois mois et
nous on dit puisque c'est mis en place
et acceptées par tous pour 1er janvier
pourquoi pas le faire sur ce tour de
france et pour démontrer que que tous
les coureurs ne sont pas dopés pas 92%
outre ces mesures les directeurs
sportifs bien décidé à ne pas être les
boucs émissaires de l'affairé festina
réclament une table ronde l'époque le
directeur sportif aussi de cette famille
du vélo un haut niveau lui s'il est là
pour prendre les français la fédération
française enfin il faut que tout le
monde doit s'impliquer pour que l'on
reprenne du crédit auprès du public et
on va reparler et votre confort et ils
vont trouver une solution et ça c'est
positif
l'initiative fait l'unanimité sur le
tour mais il faudra du temps pour
démontrer l'efficacité de ces nouvelles
mesures pour que le tour prennent un
nouveau départ dans l'anc est sûre la
sphère festina proprement dit on a
appris aujourd'hui que le médecin de
l'équipe le dr écarte avait confessé la
justice que les coureurs finances est
même l'achat des produits dopants une
caisse noire servait donc à des achats
pour l'ensemble de l'équipe dont les
coureurs devraient être très
prochainement d'ailleurs entendu par le
juge d'instruction
par ailleurs le milieu du cyclisme se
met à parler un ancien coureur de
l'équipe casino frédéric pontier
aujourd'hui redevenu amateur avoue qu'il
a pris régulièrement ce fameux produits
dopants à l'origine du scandale
le p o olivier caroff eric delhaye pour
devenir coureur professionnel frédéric
gontier s'est longtemps entraîné sur
cette route de provence pour rester chez
les pros c'est une autre forme de
préparation qu'il a dû suivre une cure 2
p o
un produit dopant c est complètement
content
c'est directement oui justement c'était
un nombre entretien entre les entre le
docteur et moi les docteurs et moi pour
pouvoir comprendre que ces produits que
ça pouvait m'apporter les effets que
cela pourrait avoir un message vous
mettez sur deux quand même le dire est
que
le docteur le docteur c'est dr malick sy
les docteurs ya quelqu'un il y avait
celui de l'équipe h pour lire ses
premières injections il les a faites au
bout de deux ans et demi de carrière un
peu après cette course il était alors
dans l'équipe aubervilliers puis en 97
il court pour casino
il reçoit d'autres propositions de
dopage clairement dit qu on pourrait
vous me proposez c'est à dire que ces
deux produits anabolisants et et autres
donc ces produits d'amgen j ai su rester
dans ma politique de personnel pourquoi
je voulais pas toucher à autre chose que
ce que j'avais déjà pratiquées et c'est
un médecin qui vous a proposé des
anabolisants médecins et dopage cela
tient du couple infernal mais avec
l'arrestation du docteur ryckaert chez
festina c'est tout un système qui
apparaît un système où rien n'était
laissé au hasard
il y avait même un pot commun pour
l'approvisionnement les primes que
gagner les coureurs servaient à payer le
dopage caisses noires stocks de produits
la direction de l'équipe festina
semblait très organisés face au dopage
certaines équipes ont réagi d'une toute
autre manière
chacun avait son produit à ses produits
dans ses bagages
ça c'est la direction l'équipe s'il
avait demandé dans toute protection des
dirigeants est dit qu elle voulait pas
que ça soit dans le même camion
non révolte à qui ce passe des histoires
comme s'est passé pour son ancien patron
vincent lavenu directeur sportif de
l'équipe casino n'a pas souhaité un banc
tu es avec nous les problèmes du dopage
sachez encore que les députés envisagent
très sérieusement de former une
commission d' enquête sur les problèmes
du dopage dans le sport en france et
pour en revenir à la compétition
première étape très difficile
aujourd'hui dans les pyrénées froid
mauvais temps tout y était de nombreux
abandons et le retour en jaune les
favoris l'allemand jan ullrich florent
gautreau alain poirier résumé début de
tour s'invite en montagne les routes se
met à écrire et les banderoles
commencent à fleurir messages
subliminaux pour les coureurs slogan
embêtant pour les organisateurs l'ombre
des festina plane encore paradoxal pour
un jour sans soleil où le riche n'a que
faire de la vox populi il imprime son
rythme de favori il contrôle et laisse
partir
élima 6 et vasseur dans le brouillard du
tourmalet vasseur voulaient s'échapper
et rééditer son exploit de l'an passé
j'essaie de m'inspirer de ça pour pour
passer les cols devant je me suis dit
que je pouvais je pouvais le faire j'ai
beaucoup travaillé la montagne 7 ces
derniers temps et donc je récolte tout
naturellement une frite c'était tout ce
travail mais vasseur va souffrir car
derrière où le riche accélère l'allemand
change de braquet
seuls les plus costauds suivre rice
pantani et le blanc tout cela jalabert
lui dimas il a calé dans le col de
peyresourde il perds des secondes
importantes et quelques
j'ai fatigué sur la fin en plus en plus
en général mais si la petite
particulièrement gêné je suis très déçu
du premier corps et les bons mois dans
la dernière descente
alors que bon j'aurais pu limiter un
petit peu plus les dégâts moi j'ai
encore quatre roues est booké quoi le
bouquet du vainqueur
rodolfo masse il voulait plus que ses
deux compagnons d'échappée dans le
dernier col vasseur et elie ne peuvent
pas suivre le démarrage de l'italien
diablement bien inspiré sur ce coup là
derrière pantani réagi mais un peu tard
le meilleur grimpeur du monde a beau
sprint et dans la montagne ou ne
reviendra pas massi sauf une étonnante
victoire à luchon mais comme prévu seoul
riches qui fait la bonne affaire au
classement général l'allemand possède
plus de deux minutes d'avancé sur
jalabert plus de 4 sur pantani il sera
difficile de lui faire quitter sa
tunique préférées on saura demain ce que
le gouvernement a décidé en matière
d'impôts apparemment il n'est plus
question de taxer les oeuvres d'art dans
le décompte de l'impôt sur la fortune
mais de modifier le calcul de l'avoir
fiscal et surtout de changer d' alléger
le système de la taxe professionnelle
payée par les entreprises jusqu'à
présent les sociétés à forte main
d'oeuvre était pénalisé sébastien
guibert alain le catch quand philippe
lécuyer a repris il ya 15 ans
l'entreprise de son père il pouvait
compter sur 40 salariés
aujourd'hui la société emploie 300 de
personnes aient investi les marchés
belges italiens aux chinois pour y
vendre ses systèmes de détection anti
incendie l'allègement de la taxe
professionnelle viendrait pour philippe
lécuyer à point nommé la taxe
professionnelle qui pour nous représente
3 millions de francs si on pouvait
effectivement arriver à ce qu'elle ne
soit plus à six sur la sur les salaires
ça nous permettrait
une réduction de l'ordre d'un million de
francs et ce qui est certainement un
meilleur notre compétitivité par rapport
aux concurrents internationaux auxquels
nous sommes maintenant obligatoirement
confrontés les affaires vont si bien
qu'en cinq ans philippe lécuyer a dû
embaucher 70 % d'effectifs
supplémentaires
du coup la masse salariale a grimpé et
la taxe professionnelle à suivre et pas
question de remplacer les salariés par
des machines
la valeur de leur travail pour des
petites et moyennes séries est une des
clés de la réussite de l'entreprise pour
autant l'allègement de latex peut-il
rapidement créer des emplois non ça peut
pas être un outil de création d'emplois
immédiats c'est un outil de croissance
et c'est par la croissance qu'on va
créer l'emploi
c'est par la croissance des commandes
par la croissance des ventes qu'on va
générer plus de besoins plus de besoins
en production et donc de l'emploi
les patrons des petites et moyennes
entreprises étudieront donc
attentivement les modalités précises de
cet allègement mesure que beaucoup
d'entre eux réclamaient depuis plusieurs
années la pastille verte qui permettra
aux voitures les moins polluantes de
circuler même en cas de pic de pollution
commence à être expédiés chez les
particuliers vous pouvez aussi vous la
procurer dans les préfectures elle
entrera en vigueur le 17 août prochain
il n'est donc pas inutile de revenir sur
les conditions d'accès à cette pastille
et de voir quel est le sort réservé aux
autres
josé blanc la pierre et pierre laurent
constant guichets des cartes grises cet
après midi à la préfecture de police de
paris
dans la file d'attenté aucun conducteur
ne s'est encore une surprise l'attend à
la caisse
la remise en main propre est gratuite de
la toute nouvelle pastille verte
je me suis dit c'est une voiture et 97
cents par le droit donc je suis à moitié
surprise mauvaise surprise en revanche
pour ceux qui n'auront pas droit à un
petit cadeau
me donne pas ce que l'on vit son
véhicule et de bell et pizza dès 1995 va
la réaction d'un véhicule c'est une
poubelle
la pastille verte ou encore le droit de
rouler les jours de pics de pollution
est réservée aux véhicules à essence
mise en service après le 31 décembre 92
aux véhicules diesel
après le 1er janvier 97 les deux roues
les bus et les camions ne sont pas
concernés
commentaire suivant notre but c'est sans
doute ce qui se passe les camions le
camion de la poste pour ne pas les citer
sont beaucoup plus pollueurs que la
plupart certaines les listes depuis le
15 juillet 700 pastilles vertes sont
délivrés chaque jour à paris environ une
vous trois véhicules
à noter que la plupart des taxis en
fonds privés les voitures neuves
non mais pas beaucoup un parc est assez
problématique
ça va être la retrouver dans la rue
des cortèges de taxi à partir du 17 août
voici qui aura le permis de circuler les
jours de pics de pollution et pastilles
vertes les bonnes plaques
d'immatriculation père les jours pairs
et impairs les jours impairs et deux
roues le covoiturage les transports en
commun et de rogations préfectoral et
bien sûr véhicules au gaz et électrique
si vous faites régulièrement votre
marché ça ne vous a sans doute pas
échappé les prix des fruits en ce début
d'été flambent les cerises on était
inabordable pour beaucoup d'entre nous
les pêches sont chers la cause est bien
la météo du printemps et sa conséquence
la pénurie qui a suivi les reportages
virginie fichet et thierry money ya plus
de 6 rue de la saison est terminée
monsieur vous vous levez le matin yann
moix et cette année les vendeurs n'ont
pas chanté longtemps le temps des
cerises au mois d'avril le gel a par
endroits détruit près de 75 % des
récoltes c'est bien meilleur qu'il nous
reste à coups reçus en ce faire les
derniers rescapés se sont arrachés à
prix d'or mais dans move y ait au moins
un point
c'était super cher aulas la saison
jusqu'à 49 cents kilos je vous assure
marie 70,6 quant au péché aux abricots
certaines variétés très chiant napoles
abricots il y en a presque pas un n'a
pas fait sourire
je décide pas un peu récolte inexistante
ou médiocre les fruits de l'été n'ont
décidément pas la pêche
habituellement cette coopérative de la
drôme collecte 12000 tonnes de fruits
cette saison elle disposera d'à peine
8000 tonnes les fruits sont rares
conséquence ici aussi il a fallu payer
plus cher les producteurs en afrique où
y fait maintenant quatre ans de plus que
l'an passé à la vente et en paix c'est
un peu moins sensible à 1.50 opus déjà
plus intéressant
le pôle it or justement cet
arboriculteur lui s'estime heureux il
n'a perdu que 25% de sa production de
pêches et d'abricots
ailleurs dans le département certains
ont vu la moitié parfois même la
totalité de leurs récoltes gelé sur
l'art pour eux la flambée des prix n'est
qu'une maigre consolation quand on a une
perte de 20 pour sa trente pour ça on
peut espérer que le marché rattrape les
choses on va un petit peu mieux il ya un
peu moins d'un peu moins de fruits de
récolte c'est vrai qu'on peut espérer
que ça rattrape le carton à des
pourcentages de pertes qui est à hauteur
de 5 m pour ça
j'irai à partir de 40 pour ça on l'a le
marché peut plus rien rattraper au delà
du manque à gagner les producteurs
craignent à long terme de fer dhr des
débouchés sur les étalages les fruits
italiens sont toujours en embuscade
la coupe du monde de football profitent
aux plus hautes autorités de l'état
selon le baromètre bva à paris match le
président dans la république obtient ce
mois-ci 67 % de bonnes opinions +1 7
point par rapport au mois précédent et
pour la première fois jacques chirac
devant sionnel jospin qui avait qu'une
aux deux points atteint 65% d'opinions
favorables plus prosaïquement la coupe
du monde de football a également profité
aux vendeurs de téléviseurs et de bière
vincent fourcade jocelyn lermusiaux le
mondial 98 avait décidément tout pour
plaire aux téléspectateurs des heures de
diffusion idéal une équipe de france
conquérante
résultat une hausse des ventes de
téléviseurs de 40 % par rapport à la
même époque qu'il y a un an
à noter l'engouement spectaculaire pour
les modèles haut de gamme
il s'est ainsi vendu deux fois plus de
postes grand écran cette année que l'an
passé
un score quasi inespéré quand on sait
que 95% des ménages français sont déjà
équipés en téléviseurs mais c'était sans
compter sur l'envié de goûter aux
nouvelles technologies
ce sont les téléviseurs en format 16/9
donc téléviseur principal familiale
poursuivre à la fois à tout ce qui est
filmé et aussi la coupe du monde
les combinés comme téléviseur secondaire
pour pouvoir suivre autre chose que la
coupe du monde pendant l'événement et
les magnétoscopes sur lesquelles les
ventes ont été relativement forte ceux
liés aux à l'enregistrement que les
clients souhaitaient faire pendant les
matchs des produits qui devance très
nettement certains modèles futuristes
beaucoup plus onéreux seulement quatre
de ces écrans géants seront vendus en
france
mais la coupe du monde a également brisé
les ventes des canettes de bière 51 %
d'augmentation dans les grandes surfaces
comme ici dans cet hypermarché proche du
parc des princes ça a dopé les ventes
saas et faire ce que vous allez nous
montre ce portable sonne au parc des
princes et cinq ou six matches on ne
veut pas que tu vas en a vendu comme
beaucoup de plus de bière que d'habitude
mais je pense que le temps il ya joué
aussi un petit peu le beau temps les
chaleurs à 60 enfin de retour les
brasseurs ne sont sûrement pas les seuls
à s'en féliciter
affaire du sang contaminé ce soir sur
les trois ministres mise en cause
laurent fabius edmond hervé georgina
dufoix de ont fait savoir laurent fabius
et edmond hervé qu'il n'opte pourvoirait
pas en cassation ils comparaîtront donc
devant la cour de justice de la
république
réservé aux politiques et apparemment
les charges retenues contre eux pour
homicide involontaire sont assez dures
thierry curtet bruno l'hiver tout
laurent fabius georgina dufoix edmond
hervé seront jugés rapidement sans doute
à la fin de l'année en fait aucun des
trois ministres ne se pourvoit en
cassation après la publication de
l'arrêt qui les renvoie devant la cour
de justice dans ses 225 pages la
commission est sévère avec les trois
ministres pour laurent fabius
elle pointe ni retard coupable en
matière de dépistage obligatoire pour
protéger le laboratoire français
ainsi le premier ministre et son cabinet
ont fait en sorte comme le leur
demandait la société diagnostics pasteur
de gérer astucieusement le calendrier de
cette mesure sanitaire
conséquence le test de l'américain
abbott est donc arrivé avec retard sur
le marché idem pour le ministre des
affaires sociales
elle se voit reprocher son absence de
décision elle n'a pas rendu obligatoire
assez tôt l'utilisation de produits
sanguins a chauffé pour la commission
l'inaction de georgina dufoix dans ce
domaine de santé publique et
susceptibles de caractériser un
comportement de négligence fautive
c'est en matière de prélèvements chez
les donneurs à risque que la commission
accroche l'ancien secrétaire d'état à la
santé
en ne prenant pas les dispositions pour
que soient rigoureusement assurer la
sélection des donneurs en n'interdisant
pas les prélèvements carcéraux le
secrétaire d'état a des preuves de
négligences estiment les magistrats
du côté de la défense on estime que la
commission réécrit ici l'histoire de la
commission d'instruction refait
l'histoire avec les connaissances notre
scientifique d'aujourd'hui nous avons
apporté un sombre de réponse nous avons
apporté un certain nombre de documents
un sombre de précision dans formulé des
demandes dans des demandes expertise
pour tout cela nous n'avons pas été
entendus pour les ministres comme pour
les victimes
le souhait maintenant clair d'un procès
le plus rapidement possible pour que le
débat soit public au front national jean
marie le pen étant inéligible pour deux
ans ils envisageraient que son épouse
prennent la tête de la liste du front
national aux prochaines élections
européennes intéressées fait savoir dans
un entretien au journal france soir
qu'elle n'est pas au courant de ce
projet de son mari et qu'elle ne
souhaite absolument pas prendre cette
responsabilité grotte trente mille fois
millénaire enquête de paternité en 1994
le spéléologue jean marie chauvet avait
découvert à vallon pont d'arc en ardèche
une grotte ces lampes des peintures
rupestres parmi des plus anciennes
connues au monde à ce jour
aujourd'hui ils attaquent l'état à qui
il reproche de vouloir le priver du
droit d'exploitation de sa découverte
françoise valais léo lambert temps
le 18 décembre 94 attiré par un courant
d'air à travers une cavité trois
spéléologues découvre une grotte
extraordinaire sur les parois 300
peintures d'animaux datant de trente et
un mille ans avant jésus-christ un
événement mondial
jean marie chauvet co découvreur de la
caverne avec ses amis étaient en
promenade privé fonctionnaires du
ministère de la culture il porte plainte
en 96 et accusent l'état de s'être
approprié la grotte sont avocats
reprochent à l'administration d'avoir
antidaté un document afin de faire
croire que la découverte avait eu lieu
au cours d'une mission professionnelle
aujourd'hui le juge d'instruction estime
qu'il ya des charges suffisantes et
renvoie trois hauts fonctionnaires
devant le tribunal correctionnel pour
faux en écriture une télé de la
retrouver
je suis pas spécialiste et est évaluée
comme étant 30 ou 35 fois supérieur à
l'intérêt du précédent de la vôtre
lascaux c'est dire si les scientifiques
et experts vont avoir une matière un
matériau fondamental à travailler mais
c'est vrai également qu'à côté de cela
il va y avoir toute une exploitation de
l'image de la grotte et qui a absolument
aucune raison de mes clients étant les
inventeurs liste grotte qui n'y
participent pas leur mission
si le tribunal donne raison à jean marc
sauvé ses amis cette fois ils auront
leur mot à dire sur l'exploitation
commerciale et scientifique de la grotte
en papouasie nouvelle guinée le bilan du
raz-de-marée de vendredi dernier
pourrait atteindre un chiffre terrible
8000 morts
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est une série
de vagues d'une dizaine de mètres de
hauteur qui se sont abattues sur la côte
sur un front d'environ 30 km de large
emportant tout sur leur passage parce
qu'elle tous ces bons
brûler les corps le plus vite possible
c'est l'essentiel du travail des secours
à l'exception des équipes médicales pas
le temps de dresser devrait sépulture
une croix de bois suffit là où le
cadavre a été découvert les vivants
sortent peu à peu de la forêt où ils
s'étaient réfugiés les médecins japonais
et australien arrivé hier doivent
soigner des centaines de fracture et la
malaria qui frappe la plupart des
rescapés les trois vagues successives
qui ont ravagé le lagon son parti du
large de l'épicentre d'un séisme et
n'ont cessé de grandir et d'accélérer à
l'impact sur la côte 200 km heure dix
mètres de haut les japonais appellent ça
un tsunami
ils y sont habitués et s'entraînent
régulièrement à s'en protéger les aucune
de leurs méthodes
les totalement efficace en papouasie on
n'en est pas là
la côte nord est la région la plus
pauvre du pays les maladies tropicales
et la malnutrition touche la moitié de
la population être frappé par une telle
catastrophe dans une région où les gens
n'ont même pas de quoi vivre décemment
c'est quelque chose de terrible les plus
pessimistes parlent de 8000 morts paris
a accordé une aide de 600 mille francs
plusieurs organisations caritatives se
mobilisent et l'ambassade de papouasie
en france en est réduite à faire appel
aux dons du public à partir de lundi
l'algérie si soucieuse de son
indépendance accepte pour la première
fois l'arrivée prochaine demain d'une
mission des nations unies dans laquelle
figurera notamment madame simone veil
l'algérie et surtout les algériens
victime d'une nouvelle forme de la
terreur des combattants islamistes
l'explosion de bombes sur les plages
gérard griesbeck jean françois renaud
reportage
du matin jusqu'au soir il reste dans
l'eau surtout les enfants
et comme sur toutes les plages du monde
on s'arrose et on rit oui mais on est à
alger sur la plage peu raïs hamidou ici
vendredi dernier deux bombes ont explosé
elles étaient enterrés dans le sable et
ont provoqué un mouvement de panique il
y a eu des morts au moins deux enfants
et des blessés depuis les mesures de
sécurité ont été renforcées
la bombe elle était explosive selon
keating et aujourd'hui ça t'empêche pas
devenir la règle à ras bord bien ce
qu'on sent mal géré et un drame petit
après on les suit on n'est pas sur la
plage populaire connaissent pas du tout
les jeunes et soeur angèle ya et il est
content de ma première fois qu'il vient
à la fois ici et sur le trajet le plus
court quoi une plage en effet très
populaire pas loin de bab el-oued
mais les bombes ont déjà fait leur effet
aujourd'hui beaucoup de familles ne sont
pas venus la sécurité reste bien le
problème numéro 1 de l'algérie même si
le gouvernement cherche à rassurer une
population qui est bien l'obligé de
continuer à vivre et cette question de
la sécurité sera au centre des
discussions de la mission des nations
unies qui arrivera dommage le
gouvernement intégristes musulmans de
kaboul fait le ménage des étrangers
encore présents dans la capitale afghane
les organisations humanitaires ont été
priés de faire leurs paquets alors que
plus de la moitié de la population de la
capitale dépend d'une façon du nom d'une
autre par don de leur présence sur les
lieux
visiblement les autorités de ce pays
n'ont plus l'intention d'être observés
par des étrangers
dorothée olliéric médecins sans
frontières médecins du monde action
contre la faim
au total trente organisations viennent
d'être expulsés de kaboul
paris cet après midi le représentant
dénoncer collectivement l'exode des
familles dans ces populations les plus
démunies le départ d
de ces associations provoque la
l'interruption brutale de cette aide
dans une ville détruite à 70% par la
guerre dans une ville où considère que
sur 1 million habitants au moins 60% la
population vit où survit grâce à cette
aide humanitaire
maintenant c'est vrai qu'il n'y aura
plus personne pour témoigner de leur
souffrance et qu il y aura donc un voile
de plus en plus opaque mais sur
l'ensemble de cette capitale et c'est
vrai que notre départ et des plus
regrettables pour la population les
premières victimes de ces expulsions ce
sont ces femmes prisonnières du voile
depuis près de deux ans elles n'ont plus
accès à l'éducation et aux soins les
femmes n'ont pas le droit de travailler
et dans les hôpitaux les médecins hommes
ne peuvent les ausculter est logique des
talibans va à l'encontre de toutes les
règles de la médecine
le médecin n'est autorisé à toucher il
ne peut toucher aucune autre partie du
corps
seulement la partie les organisations
humanitaires s'occupait des cas de
malnutrition de dizaines de milliers
d'enfants mais aussi de l'hygiène de la
santé et de l'alimentation de leurs
mails les talibans se moque des
conséquences
ce qui compte pour eux c'est la
propagation de la vertu et la
prohibition du vice ils en ont même fait
un ministère la croisière qui ne s'amuse
plus vraiment hier soir au large de la
floride l'arrière d'un paquebot a pris
feu mais quelque 3000 passagers et
membres d'équipage ont réussi à se
réfugier vers l'avant du navire
les pompiers ont pu maîtriser les
flammes en quelques heures
le bateau a ensuite été remorqué
lentement vers 1000m ce retour en france
actuellement se déroule dans notre ciel
tour de france est rien et l'on
s'aperçoit à cette occasion que la
récente crise à air france le fait que
le métier de pilote ne soit plus aussi
bien rémunérés que par le passé et bien
n'empêche en rien les vocations d'éclore
chez les plus jeunes damien thévenot
patrick roy
je consomme 28 litres à l'heure sans
quelques petites vérification de
dernière minute juste avant le départ
carburant itinéraire ou encore durée de
vol chaque paramètre est vérifiée
nicolas a 19 ans et son brevet de pilote
en poche il fait partie des cinquante
concurrents de ce tour de france aérien
une épreuve qui se déroule sur dix jours
de ville en ville avec des règles à
respecter
le but c'est d'aller d'un point à un
autre et en ligne droite le plus droit
possible et à chaque fois qu'on avait de
la ligne droite on perdait quoi vous
relevez le défi les concurrents sont
seules commandes
chaque jour 3 400 kilomètres sont
parcourus pour nicolas c'est le bonheur
à l'état pur à 900 mètres d'altitude
on n'a pas l'impression d'être dans la
même vie que quoi qu'on est au sol moi
j'ai l'impression d'être dans ce groupe
et dans une autre phase dans une autre
dimension c'est tout est plus petit donc
c'est plus la même chose
au bout de quelques heures de vol il
faut bien revenir sur terre un retour
parfois mouvementée à l'image du chemin
qui sépare le pilote professionnel de
l'amateur six ans d'études après le bac
une sélection difficile dans les écoles
nicolas et ses copains connaissent tout
ça par coeur
pourtant rien ne peut les décourager
même qu'on sait le professionnel qui
parle d'année en année le niveau
technique augmente de plus en plus
compliqué ce prison fifa c'est de plus
en plus serrés alors demande des choses
de plus en plus pointues dans plus les
domaines des domaines qu'ils vont
continuer à approfondir c'est promis
pour arriver à de telles prouesses
dimanche prochain à l'issue des épreuves
ou touquet nicolas et tous les
concurrents auront parcouru 3300 km en
tout première étape sur le long chemin
d'une carrière de pilote professionnel
pour éviter les noyades en mer pendant
durant cet été la fédération nationale
de natation à implanter 12 sites sur la
côte atlantique pour permettre à ceux
qui le désirent d'apprendre à nager en
mer ce qui n'est pas la même chose qu'en
piscine david bazié philippe du mal
faire face aux vagues de l'atlantique
c'est toujours un défi
et pourtant la formation des petits
baigneurs s'arrête bien souvent aux
limites de la piscine d'où l'idée de la
fédération française de natation
d'accompagner pour la première fois les
touristes dans la conquête du grand bleu
face à cet océan qui ne connaissent pas
il refuse complètement d'y aller par
peur par méconnaissance ou alors au
contraire ils y vont ils s'y jette entre
guillemets sens mais connaissant les
dangers que cela peut représenter
et là on arrive quelquefois
malheureusement à l'accident quoi
voyez vous veniez dans la zone basse
délimitée par les drapeaux bleus 179
décès par noyade en mer durant l'été 94
c'est le dernier bilan dressé par le
ministère de l'intérieur
aujourd'hui la surveillance est stricte
sur la côte atlantique
interdiction de patauger hors zone de
baignade pour cause de buy in win buy-in
c'est un trou d'eau qui se vide donc aux
descendants et qui emporte les personnes
à 200 250 mètres au large mais
l'étendard de la sécurité c'est un peu
le plaisir en berne quand la vague peut
être une amie
sans vous voyez ça il faut vite passer
dessous est en fait la lèvre tombe
derrière vous mais vous vous êtes passée
donc il faut se jeter lorsque la vague a
ri il faut se jeter à travers et pas
attendre que la vague ne tombe dessus
et oui même le monsieur qui tient la
caméra doit se jeter à l'eau car
l'information piscine grandeur nature
s'adresse aussi aux grands qui boivent
la tasse
suite des défilés haute couture de
l'hiver prochain aujourd'hui ce soir
nous exactement chanel et lacroix nicole
cornu langlois bernard coeur pour
comprendre vraiment ce qu'est la haute
couture il suffit de regarder ces images
expression de l'esprit christian lacroix
de la culture est pure de la couture
culture
ainsi ce tailleur en 2000 travail et de
galons franges et à col de fourrure
brodé avec jupe portefeuille constellé
d'arabesques que lumineuse est le
symbole de la profession de foi de ce
créateur qui déclare son attachement aux
faits main qui fait tout hommage aux
artisans de plus en plus artiste dont le
savoir calme ses angoisses
cette année les peintures de vélasquez
sont à l'origine de son imaginaire
n'envie de pénétrer dans des pâtures de
l'esprit 2 paraît seulement la sq à
l'occasion barran on peut même aller
jusqu'à jusqu'à dhabi c'est la peinture
espagnole et sa noirceur qui pour moi
est à la fois plein de de religiosité et
de sensualité
dr autisme parfois mais en même temps
d'une lumière fabuleuse même si on est
dans le noir entre le magic et le
perfectionnisme entre le païen et le
sacré entre nostalgie et ivresse de
vivre cette collection a suscité
beaucoup d'émotion et une ovation
à l'opposé dans les salons de la rue
cambon karl lagerfeld propose pour
chanel en hiver monacale en sandales
jupe en biais et même les vestes ne sont
plus ce qu'elles étaient quelques
brillance le soir une nouvelle plus
ample les bijoux sont sobres le collier
écharpe encore à il rehausse une robe
stricte une élégance discrète mais
évidente
retour sur un succès cinématographique
de 1996 un film anglais les virtuoses
histoire d'une fanfare municipal d'une
commune minière en pleine crise et qui
connaîtra un succès national dans le
pays
le film était tiré d'une histoire vraie
la ville minière est réellement en crise
victime de l'exploitation du charbon et
la fanfare reste le témoin de la vie de
cette région
reportage olivier lenuta fédérer
m
e
quelques notes de musique qui redonne
momentanément vie à une mine abandonnée
du sud yorkshire de l'angleterre
la mine de guam sort pas cessé toute
activité il ya plus de cinq ans fin
janvier 1993 après plusieurs mois de
grève les mineurs sont tous licenciés
par le gouvernement britannique
un petit groupe de résistants tente
alors de préserver l'essentiel trouver
des subventions afin de sauver leur
culture leur âme leur fanfare créé au
début du siècle
nous sommes très fiers que la fanfare ne
représente elle fait partie de notre vie
mais l'enfance et ce jusqu'à l'âge
adulte
la fanfare reflète l'esprit la culture
la musique du village de guan forme
deux gros hameçons collery bandes l'une
des plus prestigieuses renforts dont
l'histoire a été mise en lumière dans
les virtuoses un film qui raconte
comment des ouvriers musiciens ont
remporté le premier prix au concours
national de fanfares quatre jours
seulement après avoir rappelé la
fermeture de leur mine
aujourd'hui les cuivres de guam sort
continue de vibrer en angleterre mais
également à l'étranger
c'est évidemment un grand honneur
les gens sont fiers qu'ils ne font pas
représenté en village à l'étranger ils
sont fiers que la fanfare sur le porte
drapeau de tout leur région l'om se
noyait dans la torpeur des villes
minières du nord de l'angleterre compte
5000 habitants 45 % de la population
active est au chômage
une cité giflé par le destin mais qui
n'a jamais perdu son unique fierté une
simple fanfare aujourd'hui sauvé grâce à
la volonté de quelques hommes devenus
eux aussi des virtuoses les virtuoses de
l'espoir
il ya vont nous quitter le rappel des
principaux titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi d'abord catastrophe nationale en
espagne 26 mille hectares détruits par
le feu en catalogne
la population est mobilisée aux côtés
des sauveteurs mais manque visiblement
de moyens le gouvernement confirmant à
demain qu'il ne taxera pas les oeuvres
d'art dans le calcul de l'impôt sur la
fortune et qu'il changera le calcul et
allégera la taxe professionnelle qui
pèse elle sur les entreprises
dans un instant la météo isabelle
martinet je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne dont soir à
demain
faites preuve de